you may think of it as something that
helps you communicate with your friends
laughs it means and binge watch your
favorite TV shows others might think of
it as a way to make money perform
illegal activities and maybe even spread
propaganda regardless of how you use it
the Internet is arguably the most
powerful tool in the world so what would
happen if you controlled it how powerful
would you be what websites would you
control and could this actually happen
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you controlled the Internet
there are over five billion Google
searches every single day six thousand
tweets are thrown out every second and
billions of hours of videos are watched
on YouTube and Facebook each day if I
were to control the internet maybe I'd
make everybody watch what if all the
time and become a billionaire but before
we devised that diabolical plan how
would you even manage to control such a
powerful tool well there actually is a
way to control the internet sort of
spread across the world 14 people hold
metal keys that control the Internet all
these keys are used to protect the
Internet's domain name system this is
what allows us to type in google.com
instead of a series of numbers like two
four point six four two point eight
three the reason why these 14 people are
spread out all around the world is
because if someone managed to get hold
of all 14 keys they could theoretically
trol the entire internet so what would
happen if we hypothetically gave you the
keys to the Internet well it's safe to
say you'd be a digital God people use
the internet for everything nowadays
they talk with their friends do their
jobs watch TV so much more with you
being able to control the internet you
could have serious control over people's
daily lives maybe you'd use these new
powers for evil and shut down an entire
ecommerce company by blocking its IP
address or maybe you'd show everyone
your favorite what if videos that you
watch that week I like that idea no
matter what you do there's a good chance
you'd be filthy rich the biggest
websites in the world would all be
kissing your butt to stay on your good
side this would likely mean tons of
money gifts and perhaps some special
favors not only that but you could
choose what kind of information you want
to spread if you like a certain
politician
you could run their ads all over the
internet spreading their message to
billions of people or you could go one
step further and show everyone a video
or a tweet that you made that you'd like
everyone to see let's just hope it's not
Flat Earth propaganda despite all this
power you'll still have some downsides
to deal with sure we do have an entire
committee to control the internet
preventing one individual from having
all this power but with one person even
be up for this kind of challenge with
the power to control the Internet you'd
be the most powerful person in the world
this sounds nice but also puts a massive
target on your head
people might kidnap you because of your
fortune and influence or they might want
to harm you for how you're using your
control over the Internet so if you
really wanted to control the Internet
you'd have to live in a secret bunker
surrounded by high-level security
you could never be in the public eye and
would always have to remain in hiding
despite having so much power controlling
the Internet probably wouldn't be as
much fun as it sounds and besides if the
internet suddenly went down then what
would happen your power would be
completely useless well we'll leave that
story for another what-if
[Music]